30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become get
fear on the App Store or Google Play
hey guys it's Joanna here today is going
to be a glute and hamstring targeted
workout it's important for us to
understand that your glutes are
connected to your hamstrings and
therefore you have to work on both
muscles to achieve a stronger lower body
as well as to gain a fuller and firmer
looking but let's get started here are
five of my favorite exercises in the gym
which I do on a weekly basis to build
muscle mass you want to make sure that
you're lifting heavy enough where you're
only able to complete between 10 to 12
reps each set if you feel that you can
do more then you've got to add on more
weights let's start with Romanian
deadlift deadlift is an extremely
effective exercise to strengthen muscles
throughout your posterior chain the
Romanian deadlift variation places more
focus on your hamstrings as well as
glutes stand hip-width apart
grip the bar firmly and lift it off the
floor hold the barbell close to your
thighs this is your starting position
keep your back straight start bending at
the hips to lower the weight with a
slight bend in your knees lower until
it's just below your knees and you
should also feel a slight stretch in
your hamstrings then drive your hips
forward and engage your glutes and
hamstrings to get back up squeeze the
glutes right at the top for one to two
counts sit your hips back
to lower the barbell keep the barbell
close to your thighs throughout you
don't have to bend too low because the
primary focus is to work on your
hamstrings and glutes not your lower
back if you feel that your grip isn't
too strong then have one pump of facing
up and the other facing down
[Music]
the second exercise is hip thrust you
can maintain it the same weight as the
previous workout sit on the ground with
a bench directly behind you have your
loaded barbell over your legs I like to
use the pad to reduce the discomfort
caused by this exercise alternatively
you may also use an exercise mat place
the barbell so that it's directly above
your hips link back with your shoulder
blades rested against the bench step
your feet back closer to your boots
drive through your feet and extend your
hips up hold and squeeze your gluts for
two counts of right at the top and
slowly lower back down onto your hips
are close to the floor and drive the
hips back up again keep the movements
slow to add more tension on the
hamstrings and gluts don't stab your
feet too far out as this will not give
you a full range of motion to properly
engage your glutes you want to make sure
that your legs are in a ninety degree
position when the hips are lifted the
weights should be supported by your
shoulder blades and feet one legged leg
press to target the glutes and
hamstrings place your foot slightly
higher than normal
slowly lower the weights knee to its
chest engage your glutes and press
through your heels avoid locking your
knee right at the top always remember to
keep a slight bend this is a great
workout to activate your glutes and to
fix bansa imbalances by focusing on one
leg at a time remember that you will not
be able to use as much weight when
performing this exercise start with
light weight first especially if this is
your first time complete tentative reps
and switch over to the other leg
the next exercise will also focus on one
leg at a time
single leg lunch you'll need a bench for
this exercise get into a forward lunge
position with a back foot elevated on
the bench keep your torso upright hips
Square embrace your core with a dumbbell
in each hand bend your knees and lower
until the dumbbells are close to the
ground then drive up through your front
heel and squeeze your gluts right at the
top as you lower yourself you would the
check that your knee is in line with the
food avoid swinging your body back as
you come up as this will reduce the
tension on your gluts your body should
maintain a straight line throughout
[Music]
complete 10 - chopped reps and switch to
the other leg let's end our training
session with lying leg curl this is a
strengthen the hamstrings lightly hold
the support handles and make sure the
roller pad rests comfortably just above
the heels keep your feet hip-width apart
flex your knees and lift your feet up
and bring your heels towards your butt
once you feel the full contraction of
the hamstrings hold this position for a
second and louia legs in a smooth slow
and controlled movement this is an
extremely effective hamstring isolation
exercise do these five exercises to
target your hamstrings and glutes do
check out my other gym workouts on my
channel subscribe to my youtube channel
for more workout videos fitness tips as
well as healthy recipes and let me know
what other videos do you want more off
in the comments below
all the best